There's an asterisk
in the title of this video.
Of course there's an asterisk.
There has to be.
And I'll be honest...
I had a whole script
ready to go here
as the sun sets over the
Atacama Desert in Chile.
But, I've found so much
more than I expected
over the last day and a half.
So many stories.
I've been exhausted
both from the altitude
– we're three kilometres
up here –
and from dashing around
with handheld cameras
trying to capture everything.
So, what's going to
happen now is
we're going to cut to
a version of me
in a couple weeks' time
who is coherent
and who's had time
to process all this.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
Here's the story.
I got an invitation to visit
the Extremely Large Telescope.
Scientists love giving
telescopes names like that.
It's a telescope.
It's extremely large.
The invite was from
the UK Science and
Technology Facilities Council
and the European
Southern Observatory.
They arranged everything,
but they have
no editorial control
over what I'm saying.
And I paid for my own travel.
Those flights were expensive.
So there'll be an advert
for NordVPN later on,
because it was actually useful
to me while I was in Chile.
Anyway, the
Atacama Desert is
the most desolate place
I've ever been to.
Rolling hills
of stone and rock
for hour after hour
of driving.
I'm sure there's life
out there somewhere,
but we didn't see any of it.
Eventually, we arrive at
the base camp at Paranal.
Let me give you the
lay of the land.
At the bottom of the hill
is the Residence,
where visiting scientists
and non-scientists stay.
Not a hotel.
Very definitely not a hotel.
You can't pay for a
room there if you try.
It's more like university dorms,
if university dorms ever
won architectural awards.
That's at the
bottom of the hill,
along with all the support
buildings and structures
that are needed to
support life out there.
Up at the top of the hill
is the Very Large Telescope,
built about 20 years ago.
And a few kilometres away,
a little dot
on a flattened-off hill
on the horizon:
that's the Extremely Large
Telescope, the new one.
And that's likely going to be
the largest optical telescope
that will ever be built.
But to understand why that is,
I need to show you around.
Our first stop is at
the Very Large Telescope
– the VLT –
up on the hill about 2km
from base camp.
In theory, you can walk it.
There's a path called
the Star Track, but...
I didn't feel like
getting altitude sickness.
The VLT has been operational
for more than 20 years now.
Results from it have
won Nobel Prizes.
It was the first telescope
to take an actual picture
of a planet around
another star.
It tested Einstein's
general relativity
by tracking a star around
the supermassive black hole
at the centre of the galaxy.
And it's actually
several telescopes.
The four big ones are called
the Unit Telescopes, or UTs.
And we were visiting UT4.
Are we good to
just go in? Okay.
Oh, wow!
(laughs)
So, at Paranal, we
have four UT telescopes.
These are the large
telescopes we have here.
Where the primary mirror,
this thing that you see here,
underneath us here,
is 8.2 metres in diameter.
And that is a mirror...
very, very scientifically precise,
but the same kind
of optical mirror
that you would have just to
do your makeup in the morning
or something like that.
Um, yes, yes.
(laughs)
Lesson one:
Do not compare
the extremely expensive
scientific instrument
to a makeup mirror.
The important thing is that
the telescopes here
are optical telescopes.
That's the first reason
for the asterisk.
There are already
bigger radio telescopes.
I was lucky enough to visit
Arecibo before the collapse,
and I recently visited
Parkes in Australia.
They're all much bigger.
But they collect
radio waves, not light.
They pick up very
different frequencies,
and they're useful for
observing different objects
and doing different science.
There's stuff
you can do with radio
that you can't do with
optical, and vice versa.
Radio telescopes have
to be much larger
because the wavelengths
of the microwaves
and radio waves
they pick up
range from millimetres
to tens of metres.
But they don't have
to be as precise.
As long as you build
a big bowl
that's the right shape,
you don't need to make
a perfect optical mirror finish.
It will still work.
Arecibo's surface was just
kind of rough mesh,
but that still worked.
Optical astronomy looks for
visible light or infrared.
The stuff we can see
with the naked eye,
or close to that.
The wavelengths
are from about
100 micrometres to
100 nanometres.
And so the optics have
to be so, so precise,
just like any other camera lens.
Well actually, more precise,
because mirrors this big
have other problems.
When you get to
this large telescope,
it's actually extremely difficult
to keep the mirror stable
and in the same position.
It has 150 actuators
underneath it.
It's like poking the
mirror ever so slightly.
That must be microns.
That must be a tiny,
tiny amount it's moving.
Yeah, and this is basically
to take into account
gravity of the mirror
and the temperature difference
we have within here,
because when
you move the mirror,
then from gravity, then
the shape of the mirror
is also changing as well.
That's called
"active optics",
deforming the mirror
ever so slightly
to deal with the effects
of gravity as you tilt it,
and from thermal expansion
as the temperature changes.
That's how accurate
this has to be.
We'll come back to that later,
'cause I got to see the mirror
and those actuators
close up, but first...
We've got to explain what
that mirror actually does.
They were getting it
ready for the night,
so they had to test it.
Because the whole thing moves.
Oh, oh!
We're moving.
That's way faster than
I thought it was gonna be.
We basically
test the rotation.
We test all of the
movements of the telescopes.
We check for the
safety of the system,
before we're going to start
the nighttime operations.
You can't hear the
movement, right?
This is so fast!
Oh, we're going
back the other way.
I'm just giggling.
This is several hundred
tons of material.
It's moving like this,
and basically
it's kind of floating
on top of
this very small amount
of oil film
that's underneath here.
Because during the night,
when we're doing the
scientific observations,
we may be staying on one target.
So observing one galaxy
for several hours.
Because the Earth is rotating,
so therefore we need
to move the telescope
so that we keep pointing at
exactly the same position.
So this movement needs
to be extremely smooth,
because we don't want to add
any additional movement
onto the observations
when we're observing
our science targets.
Rotation test complete,
now the tilt.
We're going to
open the dome...
and we want to put the
mirror in such a way
that if anything falls
down from the dome,
that the probability of that
actually falling on the
mirror is extremely low.
In the middle of the desert,
constantly you're having dust
that's accumulating
onto the mirror.
I mean, large things
falling onto it
is extremely rare.
(chuckles)
I just looked over there.
Oh, wow!
So the light would
come in from a star.
Yes.
Hit the main mirror,
which is the big
reflective thing there...
back to M2 just here.
Exactly.
And then down
to M3 in the middle.
It can rotate to send it
to any two at the instrument,
or it opens to send it to
the instrument that's below the M1 mirror.
Right.
There's a lot of very bad
animations out there,
which show
satellite transmissions
and stuff like that
beaming not into the
bowl of the dish,
but to the detector,
the thing that sticks out.
And that is the wrong way round.
That's really important.
Light bounces off
M1, the bowl,
and gets focused
onto the focal point.
And then here it gets
bounced down again,
either to the
equipment at the sides
or down into the basement.
Light's going to
come in and hit M1.
Yes.
But isn't M2
in the way of what
you're trying to observe?
No, it doesn't, because
you have parallel light beams
that are arriving to the M1.
It's not going to come
across on camera,
I don't think...
But there is quite a little
white mark just there,
and a lot of dust
on the mirror.
How much is that going to
affect the observations?
For any given object
of a given brightness,
as the mirror gets dirtier,
then you'll have to
observe for longer
to get the same amount of
light on your detector.
We recoat the mirror once
every two or three years,
maintain the reflectivity.
They do use dry ice
to dust the mirrors
every few weeks,
but that can't get everything
that builds up over time.
Dust on the mirror
doesn't change the optics.
It doesn't spoil the image.
It just means that
some light
isn't reflected at all.
So over time, the image
gets less and less bright.
I did get to see the
mirror recoating lab later.
They'd just started to clean
one of the other
telescope mirrors,
the one from UT1.
And when I arrived
at the lab,
the first thing I saw was
the structure they used
to transport the whole
thing down the hill.
How on earth did
you get that thing
all the way down
the hill from UT1?
First, we have to
disconnect the cell
from the main structure
of the telescope.
And then we put this structure
on the yellow part
you can see,
which is the carriage.
And this carriage is put
on top of a truck.
And we drive
three kilometres.
This system is
over air cushions,
and we can move with
the air cushions.
Wait, it's a hovercraft?
Yeah. Exactly.
It's basically a hovercraft!
It is exactly
the same principle.
Because the mirror is
not here right now,
maybe we can go up to it.
Yeah, yeah. Let's go up.
Do you want to go up?
Yeah, absolutely.
So what you can see
from up top
is the telescope without
the mirror on it.
The mirror, I thought,
was kind of a bowl shape.
But this looks flat to me.
The sag is not so high.
It's 30 cm.
So it looks flat,
but it's a sphere.
Okay, it's just a
section of a very big sphere.
Exactly.
You can imagine that
if we make the full
bowl out of this mirror,
it will be a bowl
of 60 m diameter.
So let's go see the
mirror being cleaned.
They'd moved it into the
clean room next door.
And to start with,
it was just being washed.
Also, I realise I look stupid
with the hoodie on
under the clean room gown.
I mean, first,
it's not a medical
or semiconductor-grade
clean room.
They assured me it's fine.
And second, the reason
I'm always in the hoodie
is that we were always
going out and in,
so the temperature was
always switching from
cold, air conditioned interior
to brutally hot sun
that I needed to
cover myself from.
So it just seemed like the
best uniform for the job.
Oh, that is the mirror.
Yeah, so we have a
small window so you can...
Oh, I'm scared
to breathe now.
What you can see
is the washing unit.
Basically, it's the
place where we do
the stripping of the
coating and the washing
before entering
the vacuum chamber.
Right now, we are in the
first step of the process,
which is a first cleaning
to remove all the dust,
also all the stains
that was collected
during two years by the mirror.
And then, we can start to do
the stripping or
etching of the coating,
using this rotating arm
to pour the acid
and to have the layer going out.
So, wash the mirror
to remove the contaminants,
then acid etch the
old coating away,
and then...
When we have
cleaned the mirror,
and we will close
this big chamber,
do the vacuum, and
deposit the aluminium.
You have the
heart of the machine.
This is what we
call the magnetron,
and it's where we have
the target of aluminium.
99.9% of aluminum, very pure.
That's way beyond
what you'd normally get
for industrial use.
And by the way,
there are some shutters.
It is closed, so we
cannot see the target.
The rainbow colours are some
deposition during the process.
During years you have
these thin layers,
then it's nice.
How much is being added here?
The thickness of the coating
is around 0.1 micron,
which is very, very small.
And a micron is
1/1,000th of a millimetre.
Exactly.
1/10,000th of a millimetre.
You can basically count
the number of atoms there.
It's a 1,000 atoms' layer.
One thousand.
(heavy exhale)
The weight is around
seven grams.
Over the entire
eight metre mirror?
They atomise aluminium to
create the mirror layer.
And when I say atomise,
I don't mean like
perfume sprayer atomiser.
I mean literally,
they use plasma
to make individual
atoms of aluminium
float around in a vacuum,
and then they just let it
softly rain down
onto the mirror
until they have a coating
about 1,000 atoms thick.
Anyway, up at UT4,
the dome was opening.
So this is going to
point at the sky.
Yes.
That's obviously
a lot more light
than it would normally get?
You have the shutter in place.
So this, you know,
black curtain
that you have here is there
so no light's going
to get through there.
Oh, it's just a
physical blackout curtain.
Okay, yeah.
I can see that just there.
And I just noticed
the guide star lasers.
I know they've been
there all the time.
They've been really obvious.
But now it's pointed this way,
I can see one, two, three,
four giant laser emitters!
Those are enormous!
It's giant laser time!
But we can only see
that after the sun sets.
That's not the ocean,
by the way.
Those are clouds.
We're above the clouds.
Anyway, sun sets,
stars come out.
The Milky Way is just
stretched out above Paranal,
and it is so beautiful!
I've never seen
the stars this clearly!
And they don't seem to twinkle,
'cause there's less
atmosphere up here
to cause that twinkling,
that distortion.
The atmosphere isn't
one consistent thing.
There are different temperatures
and pressures of air,
and the light gets refracted.
It's not like wind
blowing balloons around.
The photons of light
aren't being blown away.
But it's the same reason that
an object in a swimming pool
looks distorted
when you look down at it
from above the surface.
That's a difference
in the medium
that the light is
travelling through.
The different pockets of air
that are constantly moving
about in the upper atmosphere
cause the same sort of effect.
That's why the stars twinkle.
The light is slightly
bending its path
as the pockets of air
move around.
That's the reason that
the telescope is built
high up on a desert mountain.
There is less atmosphere
to get in the way.
But there is still
some twinkling,
even if I can't spot it myself.
Enough that it'd still cause
problems with observations.
And that's what
the lasers are for.
The lasers didn't look
quite that bright in person.
Those are long exposure photos,
but they looked cool enough.
And down in the control room,
the scientists there explained
what they used them for.
This is the laser control?
In some way, it's
like a status monitor,
where we can see the status
of the laser beacons,
which are these four
images we see up here,
and also what commands
are being sent to
the deformable mirror
to correct the wavefront.
Four lasers beamed out,
camera scanning exactly
what's happening to the beams
in terms of just position?
Is it just finding the
brightest dot in the sky?
The lasers generate
a point source
that we can measure with
the wavefront sensor.
And the idea behind
the adaptive optics
is to make that point source
as tight and as
compact as possible.
So we generate
these artificial stars,
the laser beacons.
We measure them,
we apply correction to
the deformable mirror,
and that hopefully improves the
quality of the laser beacon,
and thus improving the
quality of the science image.
Every millisecond,
we're making
a measurement
of the wavefront,
and it's being
commanded to the DSM.
What's the lag on that?
It's a few milliseconds.
But the DSM is wibbling
like this really quickly.
Yeah!
Every millisecond.
That's absolutely amazing.
Yeah.
Why four lasers?
So, multiple lasers allows us
to correct the wavefront
over a large area on the sky,
providing uniform
image quality
across the science observation.
If you only had one laser,
you would get good
correction in the middle.
But then it would degrade
as you go further out.
And I figure they're
at a specific frequency
that you can then notch out
in the rest of the observations?
Exactly, yes.
This is the sodium wavelength.
On the instrument,
we have a filter
to filter out that light.
Also on the telescopes.
Yeah.
On the guide star.
So, in short,
they shoot the laser up,
see how it wobbles,
and then do maths
to subtract that wobble
from the observation.
Look, I'm gonna say
"they do maths"
at a few points
during this video,
because it's the
sort of calculation
that people spend
years learning about.
Suffice it to say,
they do maths,
work out how the laser
guide stars are moving,
and then physically move
and distort the M2 mirror
to subtract that
atmospheric distortion
from the actual stuff
they're looking at.
So, now you know
how a modern
optical telescope works,
and how precise and
difficult the work is.
That's the first thing
you need to know
to understand why
the Extremely Large
Telescope, the new one,
is probably the biggest
that will ever be built.
The next day,
we're able to go
down into the basement
underneath the four telescopes.
Because when I said
that the VLT was
four Unit Telescopes...
Yes it is, but they can
all act as one,
called the VLTI:
Very Large Telescope
Interferometer.
There is a lot of competition
for 'biggest telescope
in the world'.
There's things like the
Event Horizon Telescope,
which is a network
of radio telescopes
all around the globe.
They all point at
the same thing
at the same time,
and because
they are so far apart
on other sides of the planet,
the astronomers can record
the data that's received,
analyse it with signal
processing algorithms
and supercomputers,
and do maths,
and create a virtual telescope
that is the size of the planet.
That's called interferometry,
because the maths is all about
how those signals
interfere with each other.
We basically
completely change
the way that
we handle the data
the minute we start
combining these beams.
We're thinking about
interfering waves of light
rather than an image.
And the pattern we get from
the interference of that light
is where we extract all of
the information that we want.
Radio astronomy can do that
by recording the radio waves,
and then processing
it all afterwards.
But remember how I said
the wavelength
of radio is longer,
and the telescopes don't
have to be so precise?
Well, turns out
a lot of other things
don't have to be so
precise for that either.
Atmospheric variations are
a huge limitation
for us in the optical
because, you know, the
atmosphere is full of water.
It's full of things
that vary very quickly
at optical and
infrared wavelengths.
The atmosphere is not
varying so crazily
at radio and
submillimetre wavelengths.
So you have—
you're able to maintain
all that phase information.
It doesn't get
completely smeared out
by the atmospheric variations.
You know if there's a party
with a really loud
sound system a way away?
Then you won't hear
the treble,
you won't hear the
tss-tss-tss-tss.
But you will hear the
thump-thump-thump
of the bass?
Radio waves, and...
Apologies to physicists
watching this,
but radio waves are
the bass of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
They travel just fine
through the atmosphere
with minimal distortion.
That's why nobody
bothers sending
radio telescopes into space.
We don't need to.
But at optical frequencies,
it's different.
All the information that you
need to do interferometry,
that information gets
smudged much more easily
as it passes through
the atmosphere.
And that's not even
the worst problem.
For light, there is not
a computer in
the world fast enough
to deal with
all that information.
And there is not a clock in
the world precise enough.
Even radio interferometry
requires very precise
atomic clocks
synchronised across the globe.
But there just isn't
a clock in the world
accurate enough to do that
for the micrometre wavelengths
or nanometre wavelengths,
and terahertz
frequencies of light.
A radio wave...
You can just record it.
Even before digital
computers were a thing,
you could just record
a radio wave
onto magnetic tape.
Every single detail of it.
Every frequency, every
little nuance, everything.
Heck, a boombox from
the '80s can do that.
When people used to tape
songs off the radio,
that is a very rough
and imprecise
version of radio astronomy.
But for light, there is
not a computer in the world
fast enough
to record that data.
Not with the accuracy
required for interferometry.
So instead...
they do it physically
in real time.
Remember when I said
that the light from
the Unit Telescopes
could be sent off to the
equipment at the side,
or down into the basement?
Let's go see the basement.
So where are we headed now?
We are going inside
what we call the coudé room.
Coudé?
Yeah, this is
the room containing
the adaptive optics system
for the interferometer.
And coudé means...
Elbow.
Elbow, in French.
In French.
Okay. (laughs)
So I'm guessing
from the name
that this is a movable joint?
A hinge that can change
the direction of the light?
Yes. Then this,
the coudé,
for us, the coudé path,
is what we call
the nine mirrors.
That's a serious
warning sign, that is.
(chuckles nervously)
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay, we are
under the telescope,
and we are under what
we call the coudé path.
And this is really where
we receive the light,
which will be,
let's call it organised,
in order to bring it
towards the VLTI.
The light comes into
each of the telescopes,
it gets bounced around the
mirrors of the delay tunnel,
gets funnelled into
the VLTI lab,
gets funnelled
into the instrument,
and that's where
it gets combined.
So the light beam
isn't recorded anywhere.
It's just bounced into tiny
tunnels from each telescope.
And its next stop is
a 150 metre long
human accessible tunnel
to synchronise
all the beams.
The delay lines.
So these tunnels
run all the way
from all the telescopes
to a central point?
Oh?
Sorry.
Cannot cross to
this side of the room.
Okay, my entire
body needs to stay...
This is the boundary.
Alright, thank you.
(chuckles) Sorry.
Okay, so I'm not going to
go near their equipment
if I'm told not to.
But in my head, I'm like,
that's a little strange.
That looks like fairly
heavy infrastructure.
Surely I can't do any damage
if I accidentally just...
bump up against it?
Well, the light arrives
in the delay lines
in that tunnel from the side.
It hits a series of mirrors
designed to synchronise
all the beams,
and each beam is
bounced up the tunnel
to one of the carriages
and reflected back.
So how precise does
that have to be?
I can show you.
Okay.
We use the delay lines
for observation,
and you can see here
the error.
136 nanometres.
I assumed that the carriage
would be accurate
to maybe a millimetre?
And then there'd be some
electronics and mirrors in there
that would do the
nanometre correction.
But is that carriage
accurate to
100 nanometres
in its position?
The error that
I showed you there
is the precision that
the carriage has.
I understand why
I got told not to even
get close to that line.
That's incredible!
The carriages
can be moved with
100 nanometres of precision.
100 nanometres!
That's why they didn't
want me near them.
They'll have to recalibrate
each night anyway, of course,
and it'll get cleaned
from time to time,
but they don't want some idiot
potentially bumping into things
that have to be 100
nanometres accurate.
Because that's how
they delay the light
and do optical interferometry.
That's how everything
is synchronised.
No recording, no playback,
no computers analysing things.
It's analogue. It's physical.
Explaining what happens in
the science part of that,
inside the freezing
cold vacuum of...
science stuff,
in the rest of the lab,
is way beyond me.
That's the stuff astronomy
PhDs are made of.
And it's still a lot of work
to record the
interference patterns
and work back from that.
But, if all those beams
are synchronised enough...
it means they can
approximate a telescope
the size of the
entire VLT platform,
all four Unit Telescopes,
instead of just the
individual telescope mirrors.
But all those
telescopes, for optical,
have to be
physically connected.
So, we've covered
interferometry.
We've covered the
mirrors and resurfacing.
And we've covered
the sheer scale
of these telescopes.
You now know everything
you need to know
to work out why the ELT
– the Extremely Large
Telescope –
will probably be the
largest optical telescope
ever constructed.
And that ELT...
is our final stop.
If you're wondering
why I'm rocking
the extremely fashionable
combination of
awful raggedy old baseball cap
that I found in my
checked baggage,
and hoodie up...
The altitude is about
three kilometres here.
The UV index is just "yes"
'cause that's one of the
reasons they built here.
We are as close to the
top of the atmosphere
as you can reasonably get.
Let's go, guys.
Oh, we've actually got named
safety gear in our size.
Okay, there we go.
Required protective
equipment up here:
Helmet, gloves, high vis,
steel toe cap boots,
and factor 50 sunblock.
The construction site
is 20 kilometres away.
Down the hill that the VLT
is on, up the next one.
It is colossal, and it looks
so much closer than it is.
My brain refused to admit
that a telescope dome
could be that big.
The construction
is 74 metres high,
86 metres in diameter.
And that...
That is an extremely
large telescope.
The main mirror, the M1,
39.2 metres in diameter,
comprised of
798 hexagonal panels.
We will make the biggest
optical mirror ever built.
That is... colossal!
We are expecting images
five times sharper than
the James Webb Telescope
that is in outer space.
Sorry, five times sharper
than the James Webb?
The one that's out there
Yeah.
beyond the atmosphere?
Yeah, exactly.
The first reason
that there's likely
to be nothing bigger
than this is sheer cost.
The cost line does not
follow a linear relationship,
but it goes exponential.
So maybe you will add,
you say,
a couple of metres more,
and the costs double.
There have been plans
for bigger telescopes.
There was something
called the
Overwhelmingly Large
Telescope, the OWLT,
that was briefly planned.
It could happen.
But it'd cost
tens of billions of euro,
and frankly, the
technology's unproven.
Second reason:
We're reaching
the limits of what is
physically possible
with current
construction technology.
They're engineering
something
that is part telescope,
part skyscraper.
So it's lots of different
sections all working together?
Yeah, all the sections
are working together,
and its geometry
will be readjusted
through three actuators
per segment,
for a total number
of 2,394 actuators.
The eight metre
mirrors in the VLT,
they sag under
their own weight.
And granted, the ELT is
using mirror segments,
not a single monolithic mirror,
but keeping them
all aligned isn't easy,
and the entire structure
will still stretch and warp
as it's moved around.
And with thermal expansion
as the temperature changes.
This wall is basically
the upper foundation,
where on top of it,
the telescope will be mounted.
Right.
So this is
fixed to the ground,
and on top of it, there is
a hydraulic bearing system
that will be moving the telescope.
How precise does
that have to be,
for those movements?
We are talking
about 100/1,000,
depending on the observation,
of arc seconds.
Okay, so what does
a thousandth of an
arc second
of precision mean?
I did some maths,
and it means that
this colossal
skyscraper telescope
will move so smoothly
and so precisely
that if you told it to look at
and track a spot on the moon,
it would be accurate
to within two metres!
The actual imaging resolution's
not quite that small.
It could image buildings
about 10 metres across
at that distance,
but again...
That's a distance that can be
measured in light seconds!
We are at the limits of
what it's possible to do
with current technology.
And the last reason
– and I think the
most important one –
is that at some point,
we're going to solve
optical interferometry.
People are working on it.
Right now, it still
has to be physical.
Computers aren't fast enough.
Clocks aren't precise enough.
But they're only
going to get better.
At some point in the future,
we are probably going
to figure that out,
and we'll be able to do
optical interferometry
the same way that
we can do radio.
And as soon as that happens,
the Extremely Large
Telescope will be...
not obsolete.
It'll still be useful for
some types of observations,
because there are
advantages to the size.
Big telescopes let you
detect very small things
and very faint things.
Interferometry gets you
the small stuff,
but not the faint stuff,
because there's
less mirror surface
for the light to bounce off.
But odds are, at some point,
there'll be much cheaper
and easier virtual ways
of making
really big telescopes.
The ELT is still going to do
a hell of a lot of science
before that can happen,
if it ever does happen.
But once that's done,
maybe in a few decades,
maybe a century,
the case for building
something this big
kind of goes away,
if instead,
you can build a few
small telescopes
and piece them all together.
So this, the Extremely
Large Telescope,
will probably be the last of
the great optical telescopes.
I could be wrong.
Who knows?
Maybe in a century's time,
this will seem ridiculous,
and there'll be a
100 metre mirror
sitting high on a plateau
somewhere in South America.
But if I had to place a bet,
I think there's a
very strong chance
the ELT will be the
largest optical telescope
to ever be built.
And, as I said earlier,
NordVPN was extremely
useful to me.
I have been using it a lot,
because while I was in Chile,
websites kept showing up
in the wrong language.
They're all like,
'No voy a renunciar a ti'.
Plus, over the last year or so,
I've saved hundreds of
dollars on car rental,
because some rental
companies charge way less
just depending on where they
think your computer's located.
Same car, same contract,
same driving licence,
same everything.
I went all the way to the
final checkout to make sure.
I just clicked
NordVPN's magic button
to say I was back in the UK.
And suddenly I got a rental
for almost half price.
And of course, if you
want to watch shows
from back home, you can.
Just check the streaming
service's terms first.
You can use NordVPN on
six devices at the same time,
across Windows, Mac,
Linux, iOS, and Android.
And there's a 30-day
money back guarantee
if you want to test it out first.
If you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscott,
click the link
in the description
or scan the QR code,
then you'll get the best deal
they're currently offering
whenever you're
watching this video.